Speaker 1: This is super interesting.
When the covid relief bill passed with Joe
Biden, president, the one point nine trillion
where we had fourteen hundred dollar checks
go out to people, you, of course, I'm sure
remember that not a single Republican elected
official voted for it.
I'm not saying almost no Republicans voted
for it.
Zero Republican senators voted for it.
Zero Republican members of the House voted
for it.
People got covid cash, Republicans, Democrats,
independents, apolitical people.
People got covid cash
Speaker 3: only
Speaker 1: because of Democrats voting for
it.
Not a single Republican voted for it, voted
for it.
And we said at the time, is this going to
really lead to consequences for Republicans?
Because there are many Republicans who will
get their fourteen hundred bucks and never
find out that no Republicans voted for it.
There are many of these Republicans who will
get their fourteen hundred bucks and say,
well, I want the fourteen hundred, I like
the fourteen hundred.
I know my Republican officials didn't vote
for it, but I don't care because I still got
it anyway and I'm not going to hold them accountable.
So we had a sense that you were not going
to see punishment for Republicans for voting
against very popular covid stimulus checks
that went out.
We now have a new poll which finds that 50
percent of rural voters don't realize that
it is only thanks to Democrats that they received
those fourteen hundred dollar checks.
Americans have so far received three direct
payments from the federal government during
the pandemic.
Two were under Donald Trump, one was under
Democrats.
The first two under Trump's administration
had huge Democratic support.
And it was thanks to Republicans and Democrats
that people got those first two bills.
But the third one under Joe Biden's watch
was only because of Democrats Rural Objective
PAC.
This is a super PAC that is working to build
Democratic support in rural or rural.
As some say areas found that 50 percent of
voters in rural areas associated the recent
covid stimulus checks with the Democratic
Party.
Thirty two percent believe they got those
checks thanks to Republicans, and 11 percent
believe that it was not a partizan thing one
way or the other.
Seven percent weren't sure.
So this is a problem for Democrats for several
reasons.
Number one, Democrats are failing to connect
with rural voters since they have half of
them have no idea that it is because of Democrats
and Democrats alone that they got those fourteen
hundred dollars.
And then the second part, the second problem
is it seems as though Republicans are mostly
going to get away scot free with no or almost
zero consequences for opposing the covid stimulus,
which was very, very popular.
If you're looking for some good news, those
same rural voters were asked that enhanced
and extended unemployment.
Who do you have to thank for that?
Most of them knew that that did have to do
with Democrats.
Now, what's weird is it's all in the same
bill.
It's you know, I don't know.
This is the type of stuff that people like
Rachel Betook offer and others study and maybe
maybe could explain it to us.
But this does not bode particularly well for
Democrats in a number of different ways.
And these are really not matters of opinion.
I mean, there is a group in this country that
just has no idea what's going on around them.
There's no other way to say it.
These are not matters of opinion.
There are you know, we've talked before.
There are people who like the Affordable Care
Act but hate Obamacare.
And there are people who are skeptical of
Obamacare, but would be OK expanding the Affordable
Care Act.
And of course, it's the same thing.
They don't.
It's the same thing.
This is not the we are not talking about an
opinion about things, we are talking about
facts and a large swath of the population
that is clueless to the facts.
Now, some of them are uninformed.
As the poll said, 11 percent think that the
covid stimulus had nothing to do with Republicans
or Democrats.
Seven percent just weren't sure.
So some people are really uninformed.
Some people are misinformed.
They believe something that is absolutely
not true because it's been fed to them in
some way, shape or form.
They've been fed the same lies for decades.
They fall for all of them.
It's not surprising.
And they can't tell whether something is fact
or fiction.
And often they can't tell whether a statement
is a statement of fact or a statement of opinion.
Fox News is misinforming them.
Republicans are misinforming them.
Trump misinformed them.
You know, Sinclair on TV stations are misinforming
them and they don't know any better.
There's not really any clear way to get them
out of the right wing bubble.
They watch right wing TV, they listen to right
wing radio.
They go on Facebook and see things shared
by people who have the exact same beliefs.
They go to their church and often get a lot
of the same stuff.
They have no idea what is going on.
And so the question we're continuing to grapple
with, to which I don't have an answer, I wish
I wish I did, but I don't have an answer.
How do you deprogram seventy five million
trumpet's?
How do you do it?
And we've talked before about the retail strategy,
which is you on a one on one basis, develop
a relationship with people over time and slowly
change their views.
It can take weeks or months.
The retail strategy, unfortunately, is not
likely to be the nasty programing that we
need.
What would be a wholesale strategy that would
work?
I don't know.
I don't even know how to break these people
out of their echo chamber filter bubble.
So we continue to search for answers to that
is where we'll leave it today.